what's going on guys let's talk about
Avatar the way of water this is going to
be my spoiler review on this film so if
you have not seen the film yet watch
this video after the fact unless you're
okay with being spoiled if you are then
let's dive in get it dive in pun
intended Avatar the way of water is
probably the most beautiful film you've
ever seen in the cinemas to date it
blows away Dune and dune to me was
phenomenal it was amazing to see it in
the theaters a year ago this supersedes
that by five or ten and you need to see
this in 3D even if you say well Bobby I
get dizzy in 3D you will not get dizzy
with this film this is a beautiful film
that needs to be seen this way we've
never seen CGI this way we've never seen
Graphics this way we've never seen
Underwater World created this way
nothing looks big at all only one thing
sort of looks a little bit off in just a
hair and I'm talking because the level's
so high in this film is when they create
little baby Nabi and they're floating in
the water that one you kind of go okay
they didn't really use a real baby I
don't think because it looks a little
bit too CGI you only notice that because
everything else looks so freaking real
it's mind-blowing that they created all
these sea creatures and the detail from
their skin the textures of the scales to
everything is like it's it's not a film
guys this is an experience this is an
experience you need to see now in terms
of the storyline think of it this way if
you compare to Avatar the first one like
Dances with Wolves this is Dancing with
wolves part two you know when they leave
the reservation and they go on another
land with their family and their tribe
that's kind of what this is about except
at this point in time Jake Sully and his
family has four kids by the way he's got
two sons one daughter and one adopted
daughter uh From Grace Augustine who has
a sort of hybrid Navi daughter we don't
know exactly how this came to be they
plant some seeds but they don't answer
it in this film so if you're wondering
if they do they do not some reviewers
hated that I actually like it because it
sets up three and four quite well
there's also this young boy called
spider who is a human that lives with
among the navi kind of like Tarzan in a
way and he looks kind of like Tarzan too
but blonde hair and dreadlocks and yeah
he paints himself with little blue
stripes once in a while but yeah it's
Tarzan what we're seeing in this film is
Jake Sully who is now this he's always
been a war he's a military guy he's a
father that is very strict he treats his
kids silver like soldiers in some ways
but that's kind of like what most
military fathers out there they're so
regimented at times sometimes forget
that emotional level they need to have
with their kids which Nate Terry sort of
reminds Jake along the way but the one
thing that Jake does face now is being a
great warrior he's also very protective
of his family to the point he's willing
to run away from a fight to protect his
family and that is what this film is
about so he leaves the forest he goes to
the ocean hence the way of water with
the medic hyena tribe him and his family
now have to adapt to a new way of life
which is with these water people so to
speak and they are Navi but they have
different body types that sort of have
adapted over the years too because they
live in the water so now they have to
adapt to this way of life and it's
challenging for some of the kids some of
the kids could do it better than others
so so I would say out of the four kids
the one that stood out to me the most
which is really the story is really kind
of pivoting around the majority of the
time is played by Britain Dalton he does
a fantastic job he's that middle child
where he's a little bit rebellious he
never really has the approval of his
family you know he's kind of always
getting into trouble so he wants to
prove himself to be a great warrior to
his dad or he wants to fit in and I
think for a lot of us out there growing
up we can relate to that and Cameron
does this really well with this film
with all these characters some people
say the movie's light on story I
disagree you've probably seen some of
these stories before but that doesn't
make it any less than because at the end
of the day history repeats itself but
it's the characters at that time in
history which make it more impactful
than others one could argue that and
what Cameron gets really well with this
film and with all his films is he
understands character development he
understands that we as audiences relate
to human emotions you can tell the same
plain story but everybody's going to
look at it a different way and you know
out of the four kids you might relate to
one kid versus the other or you may
really you might relate to the parents
versus the children and it's okay
because there's a pathway for everyone
to enjoy this film and that's what he
does so brilliantly with this and that's
where I think some of the reviewers have
gotten this film wrong is the story is
quite quite complex when you look at it
there's a lot of subplots happening
there there's a lot of emotional
elements with communicating with the
animals and the whales which are called
tolcons that they're very emotive
they're very intelligent animals to them
being hunted down by humans for this
their cerebral fluids that will help
anti-aging I mean it's almost like when
you look at this you kind of reassess
that where are we at it as a society as
human it's one thing to you know kill an
animal for food to live but another
thing is to kill them for our vanity or
to kill them for sport and this does put
those questions out there and it's not
to say that this film is woke it's not
at all and this film is pushing some
agenda it's not but it there's so much
emotion in this film from the animals to
the sea creatures to the people to the
navi to the humans there's so much going
on in this film that you are just filled
with emotion watching it the entire time
and if you don't walk out of this film
going
what did I just experience then I don't
know man because I did I was really like
wow this has got this is way deeper than
I thought it was going to be way way
deeper also we've got the Sigourney
Weaver who plays Curie which is sort of
her knobby Avatar daughter so we have
Sigourney Weaver playing like a young
teenager which is interesting spiders I
mentioned it's kind of like the Tarzan
boy he is the son of Colonel quartz now
so that's something they discovered
because Coral Quartz in this film is now
an avatar all the memories of the past
curl Court are in the memories and
thoughts and emotions are put into this
Avatar so think of it like the
Terminator that's this character in the
film so you're gonna see there are going
to be some elements of Cameron's past
films and this is other people have said
and that's one of them his prime
directive is to kill Jake Sully I'll be
back but there's no Arnold in this film
but maybe they put Arnold you never know
maybe Avatar three or four Kate Winslet
in this film you won't recognize her
character she speaks with an accent and
she does speak in more native tongue
than anything else so so yeah it was one
of those things where I was expecting to
really hear Kate Winslet's beautiful
voice but you will miss her if you don't
know who she is well I mean you kind of
get you'll guess who she is when you
watch the film but you know obviously we
read IMDb or Wikipedia they'll know who
the character is but in terms of the
voice acting you won't get it in the
film she really does a great job I will
say to me some of the standouts Again
Sam Worthington does a great job as Jake
Sully his growth as a character from
being a father now a leader of a tribe
to now having to protect his family to
understanding that he has to stop
running he has to now stand up to fight
natiri by Zoe Saldana does a phenomenal
job in this and if you're wondering does
natiri die in this film no she does not
I thought she was going to die because
you know watching the trailers watching
everything else I did see 22 minutes of
the film prior a few weeks back full
disclosure I hosted the Disney APAC
content showcase and there was a special
uh not screening of Avatar the way of
water but more of a series of clips that
the audience got to see which we
couldn't talk about at the time but I
thought she was going to die no she
doesn't but someone else does in their
family if you want to know you ready for
the spoiler it's the first son he dies
and it's sort of about the behest of
Loach who kind of persuades him to go
after spider who was captured on this
ship at the very end
hence a little bit of Titanic that goes
involved and he gets a shot and he
passes away and it's a very it's a big
turning point in the film in terms of
what Jake Sully and atiri do and I will
tell you what they are fantastic Nate
Terry is such a well-written character
Zoe saldan as I mentioned plays her
beautifully and that raw motion that
visceralness that Primal element of
being a mother and protecting our kids
and going after I mean she's wicked
she's awesome and at the same time Jake
Sully is equally as badass and that's
one thing that Cameron gets that I think
some filmmakers are forgetting nowadays
and everybody wants to have
representation which is very important
and they also want to build strong
female characters and Cameron has always
built very strong female characters in
all of his films and he understands this
one thing that other filmmakers are
missing you do not need to weaken the
male character to make the female
character stronger you don't need to do
that and he doesn't do that in this film
he makes natiri he makes the kids female
characters in this film very very strong
some based on more emotions some based
on the physical prowess but the same
time the men the males are also strong
and they complement each other in
various different ways if it's through
um the way that they interact or the way
that they have to solve a problem each
you're helping each other along the way
and it's brilliant how he does this and
I wish more filmmakers will watch Avatar
the way of water and go look this is
what we need to do to build stronger
female characters we don't need to make
them in weaker we just may have to make
everybody different and unique and
that's the beauty of Cameron and that's
why he is James Cameron and why is he
probably one of the best filmmakers of
our time or of all time because he
understands this and I think this needs
to be seen in today's society now more
than ever and he does it brilliantly and
beautifully um outside of that though
this film does leave you hanging for
Avatar 3 in the sense that Sully and
quartz going into a battle they battle
it out at the very very end so he does
get the best of Courts but his son
spider decides to save him because not
having a father figure in his life so to
speak or not having someone of blood
Origins he sort of relates to this
Avatar even though it's technically not
blood relation but because it is his
father and from the mind and emotions
that they've implanted in this Avatar he
does end up saving him and so it
continues on but nobody knows that he
did this so that also adds a little bit
of a kink into the mix because now the
soys have a sort of adopted spider as
their new son after their eldest son has
passed away
and how is this Dynamic going to work
what's going to happen with this this is
going to be a secret that spider's gonna
have to keep with him and it's going to
come out you know it's going to come out
so there's this drama this build this
build up that's happening here and then
also with this relationship with Curie
they also have a relationship her and
spider there's sort of something going
on there and at the same time
Kiri is trying to discover who her
father is who what her mother's really
like and she can connect in a way that's
very unique to a point where she has
this innate power where she can control
and command animals to do certain things
or see creatures to do certain things
and it's it's almost like she's got this
Godlike power almost like Neo from The
Matrix and that way it's kind of tie
into that a little bit but we haven't
seen her powers fully develop it you see
it sort of happen at the end of the film
that does save a lot of the characters
but at the same time we don't know to
the extent and who is her father we
don't know yet that's all setting up to
be paid off in Avatar three and four for
sure I gotta tell you the relationship
that really stood out to me most out of
anything the relationship between Loach
the Second Son and the toolkan which is
this sort of this whale creature the
loyalty and the relationship these two
develop and that relationship ties in
beautifully at the end of the film and
that's one thing that Cameron does again
so well is he gets that you want to have
a good time in the movie you want a good
payoff and you get a great payoff in
this film in many many ways and uh man I
walked out of the film with a smile on
my face going I cannot wait to see
Avatar 3. and so yeah that's an Essence
if you want to see the full breakdown of
the story and go to Wikipedia or
whatever the case is but go and
experience it more I've given you some
enough spoilers go experience this film
it's breathtakingly beautiful it's the
most amazing film we've seen in terms of
CGI ever to date and Cameron once again
proves that he's won the best in the
business of all time anyway those are my
thoughts on avatar the way of water let
me know your thoughts in the comment
section below if you watch this film and
if you have any questions along the way
I'll try to answer them for you if you
like this review check out more of our
reviews right here
[Music]
foreign